63 % des salariés français ne se sentent
pas impliqués dans leur travail
un peu plus d'une personne sur
le soufre dans
étaient au travail en france 24 % des
salariés se disent en état d'hyper
stress soit un niveau de stress
dangereux pour la santé
les pathologies liées au monde
professionnel se diversifie on parle
maintenant de burn out
le fait d'être en excès de travail on
parle de bord out leur nuit au travail
mais on suit aussi le burn out
le fait de ne pas trouver de sens dans
les tâches qui nous sont confiées au
quotidien bonjour je m'appelle gaël
voici mathieu est aussi fou que cela
puisse paraître suite à l'énonciation de
ces quelques chiffres
on aimerait être heureux au travail sur
24 heures nous dormons en moyenne huit
heures pour ceux qui ont un long sommeil
on travaillait à peu près la même
quantité d'heures soit huit heures ce
qui fait que pour les mathématiciens on
passe la moitié de notre temps éveillée
à travailler alors avec elle on s'est
posé cette question à l'aube de nos vies
professionnelles
comment être heureux au travail quelques
semaines plus tard on enfilait nos sacs
à dos pour partir cinq mois sur les
routes de l'europe en france en
allemagne et au danemark
notre objectif recueillir les
témoignages de personnes inspirante
ayant trouvé l'équilibré entre travail
et épanouissement personnel
alors ce soir on vous propose de re
questionner notre sens au travail au
travers de cette clé et vu qu'on a on a
et on est dans un esprit logique on va
commencer par la première
la connaissance de soi
alors j'aimerais commencer par vous
raconter une petite histoire au japon
sur les îles okinawa
les gens vivent très vieux et en très
bonne santé jusqu'à l'âge de cent vingt
ans pourquoi je vous raconte ça parce
que l'idée c'est qu'ils le sont parce
qu'ils vivent en accord avec leur ligue
1 est ce que vous connaissez liquide
gagne c'est ça
c'est l'intersection entre ce qui me
passionne ce pourquoi je suis doué
compétents ce dont le monde a besoin et
ce pour quoi la communauté serait prête
à me rémunérer en fait on peut voir
liquide gaye comme un outil qui nous
permet de trouver au mieux son identité
profonde et trouver l'activité qui ne
correspondrait le mieux
mais alors pourquoi se connaître
soi-même pour être heureux au travail ce
qui nous amène à notre deuxième point
les passions et les combats profond
lorsque l'on a fait ce chemin intérieur
il est plus facile de déterminer nos
valeurs les missions dans lesquelles on
souhaite s'investir et ce qui nous anime
julie que l'on a rencontré à copenhague
au danemark et vidéastes photographes et
community manager elle est ce qu'on
appelle une fâcheuse
c'est à dire qu'elle divise son temps
entre différentes activités pour
différentes structures dans chaque
projet pour lequel elle travaille elle
cherche des valeurs qui lui parle qui
lui donne envie d'avancer et surtout de
s'investir dans l'évolution du projet au
cours de ce témoignage
julie nous parler de l'importance de
trouver une ligne directrice est de
tirer les ficelles
on peut en fait voir notre chemin
professionnel de la sorte c'est à dire
de voir un fil rouge uni directrice vers
lequel on souhaite aller et se donner
les moyens de le faire pour arriver à
cette direction mais alors comment
réussir à s'accomplir au quotidien en
entreprise en étant pleinement soit
lorsque l'on a une raison d'être est de
travailler qui est forte on atteint une
sorte de plénitude de travail frédéric
laloux qui a analysé le management à
travers le monde explique que selon lui
le fait d'être pleinement soit au
travail arrive lorsque l'on réussit à
faire tomber ce qu'il appelle le masque
professionnels il ya des éléments
culturels qui nous amène à penser que
des choses sont acceptables ou non en
entreprise par exemple venir avec son
ego c'est à dire se battre pour sa
visibilité pour sa carrière ou faire
valoir son point de vue ou sur sa vision
des choses
ça c'est quelque chose qui est quand
même relativement bien acceptée au sein
de l'entreprise
par contre approfondir tout ce qui peut
être dans l'est
approfondir ses convictions les plus
profondes vous partagez ces espoirs les
plus intimes ou ses valeurs les plus à
l'est plus affirmée c'est en fait tout
ce qui relève de l'intuitif de
l'émotionnel voire même du spirituel
tout ça c'est le risque de se mettre nos
collaborateurs à dos alors on occulte
cette partie pourtant la loue toujours
démontre que si l'on montre 15/16 de sa
personnalité au travail on viendra avec
le même pourcentage de sa motivation
logique alors pourquoi ne mettront ne
mettrions nous pas des outils en place
pour arriver en tant que clément nous
mêmes au travail et ainsi atteindre un
engagement au sein des projets qui est
plus fort et amener des performances qui
seront meilleures pour l'entreprise mais
alors vous allez me dire c'est bien beau
tout ça mais comment manager ces hommes
et ces femmes en laissant la liberté à
chacun individuel pour l'épanouissement
personnel mais aussi de faire avancer le
projet parce que dans l'imaginaire
collectif qu'on a le manager c'est un
rôle qui est assez stricte c'est celui
qui va à cascades et les ordres qui va
donner des directives qui va exécuter
les plans d'action pourra mener à bien
le projet mais danemark mais au danemark
aux danois le danemark est ce que du
coup au danemark
ian était infirmier et il est il est
toujours d'ailleurs fermiers et
enseignants chercheurs parce que ça fait
dans la vie six mois à peine il est
toujours enseignants chercheurs est
toujours fermiers et nos pas ils nous
donnaient le concept de rôle en fait il
avait un concept qui était basée sur
notre rôle qui peuvent être données en
fait pour satisfaire les besoins du
projet et satisfaire aussi les
appétences et les compétences de chacun
le manager aussi au danemark est
quelqu'un qui va permettre de 2 qui n'a
plus le rôle de cas plus un rôle de
coach qui n'a pas un rôle de manager
ainsi dès que l'on rencontre un problème
ou dès que quelque chose on n'est pas
d'accord avec quelque chose on peut on
peut se plaindre mais on peut aussi se
donner les moyens de faire valoir notre
point de vue et nos idées en étant force
de proposition aussi se pose la question
du
rapport aux autres de trouver sa place
au sein d'un groupe c'est quelque chose
qui est important pour rebondir sur ses
propres valeurs et ses propres
convictions et ses propres compétences
d'où vient le premier argument de diane
le fermier enseignants chercheurs donc
comme le disait mathieu avec l'histoire
des neuf pôles le travail
c'est l'histoire de plusieurs personnes
plusieurs personnes qui ensemble
contribuent au bon fonctionnement de la
société de la cité au 12e siècle lorsque
l'on parlait de travail ça nous
renvoyait à la notion d'accouchement
donc le fait de créer de donner
naissance de développer nos
civilisations mais alors dans mon
travail
qu'est ce que je crée qu'est-ce que je
développe à mon échelle individuelle
à quoi est-ce que je serre mais aussi à
quoi est-ce que nous servons en tant que
collectif en tant qu'organisation vous
l'aurez compris je parle de la finalité
de l'entreprise
en fait on peut se dire que l'entreprise
c'est un écosystème à part tant à part
entière qui a sa propre son propre sa
propre âme ça son propre sens de
direction et sa propre chose à
manifester dans l'évolution du monde et
marque qui est un français qui a vécu 15
ans une quinzaine d'années en allemagne
que l'on a rencontrée au danemark
ça fait un grand tour mais c'est pour
vous dire que cet homme là était
ingénieur en électricité
il a décidé de se former pour devenir
ingénieur physicien au sein d'un hôpital
là où il trouvait à un sens un peu plus
profond au sein même de sa de son
entreprise et son organisation par
finalité de l'entreprise ils entendaient
vraiment le sens de connaître
l'importance de connaître ce que fait
notre entreprise ce qu'elle fait comment
et pourquoi est aussi se poser la
question de l'impact qu'elle a au sein
de son écosystème global en parlant de
l'environnement et de social le temps
une énorme richesse
par définition le travail c'est un temps
que l'on offre pour développer un
service ou un produit le rapport au
temps ça peut être quelque chose à
redéfinir parce qu on a à peu près 80
sentant avis sur sur la terre et ce qui
peut être atteint ce qui peut être
intéressant c'est de savoir dans quoi on
veulent investir dans quels projets et
dans quelle entreprise
on veut faire valoir notre temps et
notre énergie
lilian qui est un le co fondateur de la
coopérative d'inactivité qui porte très
bien son nom puisqu'il veulent à 3 faire
valoir la chose suivante c'est
d'intégrer au code du travail
là le choix pour chacun d'eux enfin
d'avoir pour chacun la liberté de
demander un temps précis qui il veut
travailler dans l'entreprise et lilian
nous parler à juste titre c'était
c'était assez marrant de se dire que
depuis tout jeune on nous impose des
semaines pleines des journées pleines et
ça c'est un rythme qu'on imprime et que
une fois nous premier job en poche on va
par questionner cette norme alors qu'il
serait peut-être légitime de d'équilibré
en fait profondément et librement
c'est la proportion entre valeurs dites
travail de la valeur dit libé de temps
libéré et alors maintenant vous allez me
dire mais pourquoi en fait qu'est-ce qui
nous empêche de faire ce que l'on veut
notre temps une des réponses à sa une
des réponses qu'on peut apporter c'est
l'argent parce que l'argent on en a tous
besoin on a besoin d'en gagner mais la
question qu'on peut se poser c'est
pourquoi et comment l'argent nous
renvoie au fonctionnement de nos
sociétés sous la forme de communauté
c'est à dire que l'on a besoin des uns
et des autres pour échanger échanges et
de la connaissance des expériences des
sentiments mais aussi des produits et
des services des produits et des
services
parce que l'on ne peut pas tout faire
soi même pour une question de temps ce
qui est intéressant du coup ces deux
requêtes youn et nos habitudes
au delà des normes sociales et en
enlevant aussi l'énorme canada que l'on
n'a jamais refonder voilà un exercice
qui pourrait vraiment nous permettre de
redéfinir nos propres besoins et nos
propres envies et aspirations et à
partir de ça on peut se donner la
liberté de drogue du coup questionner
notre nos envies nos habitudes et
ensuite donné un ordre de priorité à
tout cela et gagné l'argent en
conséquence et lilian nous parlait à
juste titre de la course aux biens
positionnelle la course de l'échalote à
celui qui gagne plus
il le montre plus est il le disait en
fait réduire son temps d'emploi c'est
réduire son salaire
donc c'est se demander avec combien je
dis qu'est-ce que je dépense pourquoi je
le dépense
et aussi qu'est ce que me coûte le fait
de travailler plus et pourquoi je ne
pourrais dépendre pourquoi est ce que je
pourrais dépenser moins du coup c'est
cette notion de deux trépieds entre
redéfinir nos besoins donner un ordre de
priorité et gagner de l'argent en
conséquence le point commun entre les
différents éléments que l'on vient
d'analyser c'est qu'ils sont tous
profondément ancré en nous depuis notre
plus tendre enfance et c'est l'éducation
qui est la clé pour pouvoir déconstruire
ces perceptions et ainsi changer notre
rapport au travail
l'éducation c'est ce qui nous a
construit ce qui nous a forgé ce qui a
régi notre être
elle est passée par nos parents par
l'école par notre entourage mais aussi
par nos expériences nos réussites et nos
échecs alors n'ayons pas peur d'écouter
les vents porteurs mais surtout
d'écouter de s'écouter soit n'ayons pas
peur de prendre de nouvelles voix
puisque elle ne contrediront pas
forcément celle que l'on appelait les
choix que l'on l'a fait précédemment et
l'éducation a lieu tout au long de notre
vie pendant cette expérience pendant ce
voyage éducatif que l'on a entrepris
pendant ces cinq mois en france
allemagne et danemark
on a pu découvrir et rencontrer de
nombreuses personnes qui représentaient
un large panel des formes de travail qui
existaient les quatre principales l'auto
entreprenariat le salariat en temps
partiel ou temps plein mais aussi l'auto
suffisance ou encore le slash le fait de
faire plusieurs activités comme gaël
vous disais est ce qui était intéressant
c'était de voir que au sein même de ses
formes de travail une marge de manoeuvre
était possible et qu'il était ainsi
possible de changer les choses qu'on
n'était pas bloquée dans une mais qu'il
était facilement possible de voir
ailleurs et d'aller faire d'autres
choses alors c'est pas forcément on va
changer du tout au tout au tout et du
jour au lendemain mais nous ce qu'on
vous propose c'est c'est une incitation
c'est oser se poser la question du sens
d'un au travail ou dans nos futurs
travail et ainsi définir l'activité dans
laquelle on serait le mieux
là on pourrait s'épanouir au mieux mais
aussi faire valoir nos convictions et
nos compétences
alors pourquoi ne pas tendre vers un
travail au sens propre propre à soi qui
correspond à nos valeurs qui nous parle
mais aussi au sens propre du terme
qu'est ce que signifie pour moi le mot
travailler quel concept il appose chez
moi et de questionner aussi l'utilité
sociale est ce qu'il ya une utilité dans
mon écosystème qui est visible propre
écologiquement qui répondent aux
transitions qui sont indéniablement
nécessaire aujourd'hui soyons acteurs
des gens des enjeux sociaux et
environnementaux auxquels nos
générations font face nous vous
remercions beaucoup de votre attention
et de votre compréhension
[Applaudissements]